I...
I believe...
I believe that...
I believe that we...
I believe that we will be four-time champions...
...and keep winning until we not only become the best female soccer team,...
...but the best soccer team in the world,...
...and that a whole generation of girls and boys will go out and play...
...and say things like "I want to be like Megan Rapinoe when I grow up"...
...and that they'll be inspired to talk and win and stand up for themselves.
And I believe that we will make our voices heard...
...and TV shows will be talking about us every single day and not just once every four years,...
...and then women will conquer more than just the soccer field,...
...and breaking every single glass ceiling and having their faces carved on Mount Rushmore...
...and then we'll keep fighting not just to make history but to change it forever.